another heavy-duty topic which is good
to know about is edge caching to
describe this let's look at the
information flow for your app engine
application first of all users that want
to use your application are connected to
their internet service provider this
provider connects to google data center
after the dns lookup has determined that
your application is hosted by google
google then identifies a data center
where you're at the engine application
run and starts talking to the App Engine
front end if the content is dynamic the
app and your front-end determines the
instance that you manage to request so
these are your App Engine instances that
run your application code but if the
request is for static content for
example images or static HTML the
front-end can retrieve it directly from
the static servers and in both cases the
response is returned back to the user so
this is a good architecture but as it
looks right now all the requests have to
be sent to the data center which hosts
your app engine application it would be
much better if more content could be
served directly by this data center
first of all it would ease the load on
this data center but more importantly
since it's closer to the users the
response would be delivered faster this
is exactly what edge caching is all
about edge caching is a cache that sits
in the data center closest to the user
so whenever there is a request the
result can be served directly from the
cache if it's available there rather
than going through data center to that
means less load on data center to in
your application and faster responses to
your users a win-win so the question is
then what do you need to think about to
use edge caching well there are two ways
the first one is to set the cache
control header in the HTTP response this
should only be done if the subsequent
requests of this kind would return the
same result the second option is to
define as much content as possible as
static since static content does not
change it's great for edge caching you
can define which content is static
through configuration files a good
opportunity for you to look at the
online documentation and remember as
most of the time with caching there are
no guarantees that the con
that will be cached but when it is it
will be good for both your application
as well as your users